hi everyone i'm jalana
and i'm dioc and we're both customer
engineers at google cloud
welcome back to the technical series for
startups where we're creating a series
of videos for technical enablement to
help startups to start build and grow
their businesses successfully and
sustainably on google cloud
in their previous video we deep dived
into automating your development cycle
with ci and cd pipelines
and now we'll talk about how to improve
the performance and reliability of your
applications with cloud operations
in this video we're going to cover
introduction to the cloud operations
suit formerly known as stackdriver
operation tools is means to have
observability over your google cloud
resources
application performance management tools
to improve performance and reliability
of your applications finally we'll share
a customer success story to demonstrate
the value of the google cloud operation
suit
if you ever worked with on-premises
environment you know that if your
application becomes unresponsive
somebody could walk in physically check
why and resolve the issue in the cloud
though how do you know what's happening
with your server database or application
the answer is simple with the tools that
we will show you in this video
capturing of telemetry login and trace
data is done from the hardware layer and
up for google products
from these products signal data flows
into cloud operation tools where it can
be visualized in dashboards and through
the metrics explorer
automated custom logs can be ingested
and analyzed in the log viewer
services can be monitored for compliance
with the service level objectives and
error budgets can be tracked
health checks can be used to check
uptime and latency for external facing
sites and services
and running applications can be debugged
and profiled when inside is secure
single data can generate automated
alerts that can notify personnel through
various notification channels
air reporting can help operation and
developer teams to spot count and
analyze crashes in your cloud-based
services
finally all the visualization and
analysis tools can help to troubleshoot
what's happening in your google cloud
environment
let's start first with exploring the
products that tend to be of interest for
the operation folks
cloud logging provides a centralized
cloud logging system that you can use to
store search analyze monitor and alert
log data and events from all google
cloud resources but also to collect data
from multi-cloud environments with
endless integration cloud logging also
provides integration into third-party
systems through the api and cloud pops
up
the export functionality allows you to
perform aggregated analytics in bigquery
and store your logs in google cloud
storage
as you can see from this quick demo with
features like histogram logs field
explorer you can quickly gain insights
into trends across your logs air
reporting provides insights into your
errors by collecting and grouping your
application errors
there are three key law categories
audit logs agent logs and network logs
audit logs help answer the question who
did what where and when and those are
admin activity logs data access logs
system event and data transparency logs
agent logs use google customize and
package fluentd agent that can be
installed on any google cloud or aws vm
instance and ingest logs from google
cloud or aws ec2 instance
finally network logs provide in-depth
network telemetry with ppc flow logs 5
volt rules nat gateway and loan balancer
types
cloud monitoring allows you to collect
metrics from multi-cloud and hybrid
infrastructure in real time by using
cloud monitoring you can answer
important questions like what is the
load on my service
is my website responding correctly
is my service performing well to
understand the current load on a service
or to view performance data of your
servers for the past month use the
charts and dashboard tools if you're
interested in being notified if your
deployed service isn't accessible or
responding correctly then configure an
uptime check and attach an alerting
policy
this is an example of metrics explorer
where you can explore metric lists for
all gcp services and add them to
different chart types
monitoring has many predefined metric
types and monitored resources available
but you can also create custom metrics
if you don't want to save the chart to a
custom dashboard but you want to keep a
reference to the chart then save the
chart url
dashboards are one way for you to view
and analyze metric data
the cloud console provides 15 predefined
dashboards that require no setup or
configuration
your google cloud project resources
determine the dashboards available for
you
for example if your project contains
compute engine instances then your
project includes dashboards for vm
instances and for disks hey everyone the
next step is for us to check out some
tools to help you manage your
application's performance
at the heart of measuring application
performance in google cloud lies cloud
debugger it lets you inspect the state
of a running application in real time
without stopping your application or
slowing it down all at no cost with
cloud debugger you can examine your
code's function and performance under
actual production conditions
how convenient is that
in addition to real-time app debugging
cloud debugger allows you to capture the
state of your application in production
at a specific line location with
snapshots you can see this on the right
i first set up a snapshot at line 73 you
can see in the snapshot column that it's
waiting for a change
i then go to my application and provoke
a state change by clicking the add to
cart button you can immediately see the
state capture by the snapshot
specifically that the cost id variable
set at line 73 has the value undefined
moving on from snapshots you can also
use log points to inject a new logging
statement on demand at a specific line
location as well as capture a snapshot
or write a log point message only when
you need it using a simple conditional
expression written in your application's
language
the ease of use of cloud debugger is
further extended by its integration with
existing developer workflows and popular
ides
you can easily collaborate with other
teams by sharing your debug session in
this demo i can simply share my console
url with the team member and they'll be
able to see the snapshot i created
debugger also knows how to display the
correct version of your source code
because it easily integrates with
version control systems such as cloud
source repositories github bitbucket or
gitlab
now that we've seen how easy and
convenient it is to work with debugger
let me tell you what cloudtrace is
based on the tools that google itself
uses on its production services
cloudtrace is a tracing system that
collects
analyzes and displays latency data from
your distributed applications and
displays it in the google cloud console
cloudtrace can capture traces from
applications deployed on app engine
compute engine vms and kubernetes engine
containers
it generates performance insights near
real time and automatically generates
in-depth latency reports
finally cloudtrace also continuously
gathers and analyzes trace data to
automatically identify recent changes to
your application's performance
let me show you a quick demo of
cloudtrace
first when opening cloudtrace in the
google cloud console i immediately see
an overview of previous traces and a
report of latency
let's navigate to the trace list page
i'll create some filters to see calls to
a currency service of my application
that are only getting get requests which
took at least a thousand milliseconds
from request
to response
i then select the traits from the graph
and below in the trace waterfall view
i can explore the spans which are
sub-operations of this particular trace
finally under the details panel i select
to view logs which takes me to the cloud
logging page where i can see detailed
log entries associated with the request
that initiated this trace
in summary this allows you to see how
requests propagate through services in
separate projects
and helps you to identify sources of
poor performance across your entire
stack
onto error reporting
error reporting counts
analyzes and aggregates the crashes in
your running cloud services
a dedicated view shows the error details
time chart occurrences
affected user count
first
and last scene dates and a cleaned
exception stack trace
you can opt in to receive email and
mobile alerts on new errors
finally the last major component of
measuring your application's performance
is cloud profiler
poorly performing code increases the
latency and cost of applications in web
services every day without anyone
knowing or doing anything about it
to solve it cloud profiler continuously
analyzes the performance of cpu
intensive and memory intensive functions
across an application club profiler does
this by using statistical techniques and
extremely low impact instrumentation
that runs across all production
application instances to provide a
complete cpu and heat picture of an
application without slowing it down to
set up cloud profiler you first include
a language specific profiling agent in
your application
whether it is running in gc evms app
engine or gke the agent then collects
profiling data as the app runs
as you can see from the image on the
right cloud profiler presents the call
hierarchy and resource consumption of
the relevant function in an interactive
flame graph that helps developers
understand which paths consume the most
resources and the different ways in
which their code is actually called
now that you've seen many operations in
application performance management tools
how should you use them to bring your
ideas to market faster and to be more
responsive to your customers
well
google site reliability engineering or
sre is the answer
sre is how operations at google adopted
devops
the five sre design principles redefine
reliability
reduce toil
balance speed and risk
make small changes
and create the right culture
help you accomplish these goals
the tools we introduced were designed
based on google's own operations
experience and development of sre
practices
a key area of practice for sre is
monitoring
cloud monitoring which pulls data from
multiple sources
not only gives you the visibility you
need to quickly determine service health
and diagnose your applications when
things go wrong but also addresses the
fundamental monitoring needs of sre with
components such as slo monitoring
dashboards and its analytics
capabilities through default and custom
metrics
let me tell you about a customer success
story
qrikey is a gaming company which aims to
bring the excitement of interacting with
characters through augmented reality by
leveraging stories they are rarely told
in mainstream gaming
with four separate games all requiring
multiple video feeds they rely on cloud
operations to monitor troubleshoot and
improve their applications performance
in particular the cloud monitoring
dashboard gives them deep visibility
into latency downtime and the overall
health of their applications
here's a joint quote from crickey ceo
and cto
having one integrated view of alerts
slos events and logs via the dashboard
which allows us to quickly identify
which container has a problem fix the
container and redeploy
in this episode today you got to see the
fundamental components in making your
application perform better with the
consistent and effortless observability
and monitoring of your resources thank
you for joining us on this episode about
cloud operations to continue exploring
check out our suggestions on the links
in the description we'll see you next
time for an overview of billing a
critical component of your google cloud
presence
you will learn about different
discounting options how billing works
and how to manage your costs don't
forget to subscribe to our youtube
channel and to click on the bell icon to
get notified each time we post a new
video
see you next time
bye-bye see you next time
[Music]